[Music]
um counselor Paul Williams the why maker
are you District Council and I'm here to
tell you a few of the facts that's
hidden from the and the wrap-up of the
November council meeting we've approved
funding for the South Block main trunk
line that's coming into a ring you're
from the South Brook sewage system to
improve the capacity of the surge for
renderer and the counselors decided to
organize us over the school holidays so
that we not so much disruption to the
South Brook and schools in preschool in
the area
the counselor past the adoption of the
why Metairie accessible strategy and
this will go a wee bit more access for
disabled people around Waimakariri and
improve hopefully quite a lot of the
problems they're having in the area so
that's been passed and this council
meeting which is a good thing the
council have deferred payments for those
riding for disabled which have the
council's loan funded leave some funds
to buy prefab unit for the club rooms
and that near deferred the payments so
the club have a wee bit more time to
make payments to the council through
2020 so council looking after them as
best we can
and 1892 there was a gravel pit area
that was designated for their local
council then in the Waimakariri Council
near have just gone invested it as a
reserve for utilities which will give a
position to put a new water bore for
oxford community for the future planing
of oxen so that was a bit of a wrap-up
what's happened on this particular
council meeting in November and the
biggest meetings probably of the year's
going to be coming up and December where
some of the real nutty gritty and
portent but some pieces we bought up
I believe the four courts in the
three-bin system will be discussed on
that time so that will be interesting to
look forward to
[Music]
you